bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france on se souvient de
cette vaste campagne de vaccination
lancée il ya plusieurs mois déjà c'est
allé très vite le pays frôle mêmes
l'immunité collective à la mi-avril est
ce que vous êtes surpris par cette
reprise des contaminations
écoutez je crois qu'il faut tenir compte
des réalités et la réalité c'est
effectivement le variant delta qui est
beaucoup plus agressif et d'un point de
vue diffusion et aussi en termes de
morbidité donc ça c'est concerne
effectivement le côté sanitaire et puis
il ya le côté la géographie humaine la
géographie humaine est d'une traite
montre une très grande densité en israël
n'est ce pas il y à 450 habitants au
kilomètre carré si on compare par
exemple par un clin d'oeil avec la
russie où vous avez à peu près 13
habitants au kilomètre carré donc plus
vous avez des densités de population
forte plus vous avez des risques bien
sûr on est probabilité de transmission
et et donc les précautions qui vont avec
vous parlez donc de la densité de
population qui qui jouent un rôle dans
cette propagation mais ce qu on peut
aussi considérer qu'il ya eu un
relâchement de la part de populaire de
la population puisque elle a peut-être
que penser qu'elles sont et est sorti
face à la pandémie
vous avez ça c'est le problème de
comportement collectif très très
difficile à à analyser et à corréler en
tout cas il ya pratiquement 10% de la
population israélienne qui a été atteint
donc voyez vous à nouveau si on fait un
parallèle avec la russie 144 millions
d'habitants il y aurait 14 millions de
cas en russie pour la même proportion de
10% eh bien voyez vous donc la
proportion de cas en israël est deux
fois plus élevé donc il faut tenir
compte de cette réalité à la fois
sanitaire et et humaine et donc prendre
les mesures adéquates je pense que
vis-à-vis de la pandémie mondiale il
faut vraiment vraiment avoir en tête la
différence de situation
humaine la différence de pénétration de
thau donc du virus est en conséquence
d'avoir des politiques qu'ils soient
très flexible pour s'adapter à chaque
situation de chaque pays et justement
avec cette troisième dose maintenant
accessible dès 40 ans quel est le
message qu on voit les autorités que la
situation peut encore être contenue
bien sûr il faut se prémunir on voit
très bien que dans les pays qui ont les
taux de vaccination à les plus élevés
étaient bien ceux dont c'est dans ces
situations que la pandémie 3ème 4ème
vague peut-être freiné le plus aisément
entre guillemets donc il faut avoir des
taux de vaccinations les plus élevées
possibles pour avoir des taux de
mortalité les plus faibles possibles
cent mille morts dans un pays 300 mille
mois dans un pays en un ou deux ans
concernant une pandémie cela avait
quelque chose de catastrophique n'est ce
pas il faut vraiment avoir rend
le nombre de membres chaque pays pour
comprendre les décisions qui sont prises
il serait l'on peut considérer comme un
petit pays plus de 9 millions
d'habitants plus de la moitié a déjà
reçu deux doses pour la troisième ils
sont 1,2 million est ce que il faut que
ça aille aussi vite que pour la première
campagne d'autant plus comme vous le
rappelez un qu'il ya une forte densité
de population
bien sûr il faut être plus rapide que la
diffusion du virus donc c'est une course
entre la diffusion la propagation du
virus est là les opérations de
vaccination et pour gagner cette course
est bien l'équation est simple il faut
que la vitesse de vaccination soit
supérieure à la vitesse de propagation
c'est beaucoup gérard vespière pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes fondateurs du web magazine le
monde décrypté et merci à vous merci